[Música]
hoy día les traigo una historia de viaje
en realidad traigo una canción para
contarle ese viaje pero como la canción
es cortita le voy a hacer una gran
introducción y en esa introducción nos
vamos a ir 10.000 años hacia atrás donde
el hombre aproximadamente 10.000 años se
vuelve sedentario por el descubrimiento
de la semilla
y con ese milagro comienza la
agricultura comienza la ganadería pero
también quedan atrás 2 millones de años
en que el hombre más o menos como lo
conocemos deja de ser nómade cierto o
sea 10.000 años de sedentario 2 millones
de años de nomadismo la ciudad es una
consecuencia del sedentarismo la tribu
se detiene comienzan a cuidar sus
cultivos a domesticar animales pero
también al tener ciertas posesiones por
primera vez en la tierra se levantan las
murallas la fortaleza y es dentro de
estas murallas donde se empieza a juntar
la gente pero al tener posesiones debe
cuidarse también de las ambiciones de
otras tribus
también dentro de estas de ésta
de estas ciudades los roles sociales
comienzan a volverse más complejos
porque hay que administrar la producción
y son realmente más complicados que en
un grupo más simple como un grupo nómade
hoy día se estima que en el mundo hay
alrededor de 30 o 40 millones de
personas que viven como nómade
dentro de esto podríamos separarlos en
distintos grupos
como cazadores-recolectores como las
tribus que viven en la amazona como los
pueblos que viven en el ártico en el
norte
podríamos tener pastores también como
nuestros queridos jarrilleros en la
cordillera de los antes que suben con
sus ganados durante el verano a las
veranadas esos pastos maravillosos que
esconden los cerros y cuando se nieva
ahí en el invierno bajan a las
invernadas que son los pastos que están
en la costa y ahí también una pequeña
aclaración quizá uno tiene la idea de
que no me deja andar y andar y andar
pero en este caso van rotando y
escuchando los ciclos de la naturaleza
dentro de las cosas para viajar de la
la música por ejemplo es un elemento muy
fácil de llevar
se lleva en las manos se lleva en la
boca se lleva un poquito en la memoria
es capaz de pasar cualquier aduana
la música también tiene una condición
sumamente particular
es capaz de congregar a la gente todas
las personas quieren oírla y eso cuando
uno está viajando sirve mucho porque
hace amigos lo invitan y además tiene la
posibilidad de generar un poco de dinero
la música también habla un mensaje un
lenguaje que es universal
todos entienden la música independiente
de los idiomas en que se canten uno
podría trazar el origen de la música
probablemente hacia áfrica no es cierto
y todas las músicas tienen un origen
común
dentro de eso el músico que canta se
sube a un carro de una tradición muy
antigua porque prácticamente todos los
pueblos han desarrollado la voz como su
instrumento primigenio
cuando nos vamos a la tradición
occidental vemos que esto que conocemos
como cantautor hoy en día es la herencia
de el arte de los trovadores y el arte
de los juglares los trovadores por un
lado que eran más ligados a la poesía y
a la composición y los juglares por otra
parte que estaban más ligados a la
interpretación y la improvisación
ahora en el caso mío yo me crié
totalmente contrario al nomadismo en un
instrumento que es quizás el más
sedentario de todos que es el piano me
pasé la infancia y la juventud ahí
amarrado a este gran instrumento
y
cuando uno se define como un músico en
la sociedad así mismo como me imagino un
médico por ejemplo que independiente de
su especialidad tiene que ser médico en
cualquier situación
un músico también aunque sea pianista y
no pueda llevar el piano a ninguna parte
le toca estar en bautizo en casamiento
en funerales en fiestas en serenatas no
es cierto entonces que me pasó a mí
aprendí un poco a tocar los acordes más
sencillos quizás en la guitarra en vez
de estar dando explicaciones de que en
realidad no tenía el piano para tocar
y así
componiendo lo que serían las canciones
de mi primer disco salió una canción
esta no es la canción que les traje
solamente voy a pasarles una parte para
que entiendan la historia yo sin saber
esta canción se llama para cantarle a la
vida solo les voy a cantar un pedazo del
coro de esta canción
que dice algo como de aquí yo voy a
salir de a pie
no voy a llevarme nada y la saldré a
buscar
de aquí yo voy a salir de pie
no voy a llevarme nada y la voy a
encontrar
al andar
[Música]
muchas gracias
bueno esa canción que terminó siendo el
single del primer disco fue muy
premonitoria porque en ese momento yo
vivía en el campo junto a mi mujer junto
a nuestros dos hijos estábamos
terminando el disco y venía el momento
de salir a trabajar con este disco salir
a contar y cantar todas estas canciones
pero la única forma que yo conocía era
ir a la ciudad ir a las noches ir a los
bares que es donde generalmente uno
comienza su carrera pero eso era
completamente incompatible con el estilo
de vida que nosotros estábamos llevando
y con lo que nosotros queríamos
entregarle a nuestros niños
por lo tanto qué hacemos y en una noche
de conversación larga de vinos se abre
el gran baúl de los sueños olvidados y
ahí al fondo al fondo cuando lo
escuchaba mostraba ese ulises que
tenemos todos adentro gritando
váyanse a la aventura váyanse a la
aventura
y así lo hicimos vendimos algunas cosas
que teníamos juntábamos lo que pudimos
contactamos a una familia también de
bélgica que andaba viajando por
sudamérica y les compramos su casa
rodante nos subimos a la casa rodante y
nos fuimos en un viaje al cual no
sabíamos dónde íbamos a ir y no sabíamos
cuánto tiempo tampoco iba a durar
finalmente el viaje duró dos años
recorrimos chile recorrimos bolivia
recorrimos perú recorrimos el ecuador
recorrimos colombia
y ahí me di cuenta de una cosa que
también les vengo a contar que el
viajero es un arquetipo el viajero son
los dos millones de años que están
clasificados en nuestros huesos de
nómades que nos precedieron y porque les
cuento esto porque a través del canto y
a través de esta casa rodante y esas
presentaciones mucha gente se acercaba a
nosotros pero no se acercaba a nosotros
como personas se acercaba a nosotros
porque veían al viajero
el deseo que ellos tenían y venían a
contarnos su historia y se repetía mucho
el decir oh qué maravilla eso es lo que
yo quisiera hacer pero por qué no lo
hago y ahí pensando en esta charla quise
encontrar
los factores comunes que se repetían de
porque no hacían ese viaje
uno en el dinero
el segundo como nos veían con hijos era
la educación de los niños el tercero era
que su pareja no quería unos y otro no y
es cuarto creo que el miedo y ahí por
ejemplo el dinero yo les quiero contar
que es muchísimo más barato andar
viajando en un viaje de esas
características donde uno anda muy
sencillo come muy sencillo tiene muy
pocas necesidades que estar sedentario
en la ciudad con la cuenta el teléfono
el colegio el arriendo la deuda etcétera
etcétera y ahí me acordé también de una
pareja de amigos que conocimos que
andaban viajando también con su niño muy
chico
y hace cinco años viajaban sin ningún
tipo de dinero y ese era su proyecto nos
mostraron muchas formas de comer muchas
formas de invitar muchas formas de
congregar gente y de ello heredé una
frase que la quiero compartir con
ustedes que decían el universo está
atento a nuestras necesidades
con respecto a la educación de los niños
esa frase como oye que es bueno que
hagan usted este viaje ahora porque
después los niños entran al colegio y
olvídate tienes 12 años en que no puede
salir a ninguna parte quien dijo es
ponerles una corbata mente el a un
sistema enseñarles con campanas con
recompensas con castigos con
calificaciones
hoy día hay muchos sistemas de enseñanza
diferentes y más grandes y conscientes
pero creo que eso es materia de otra
charla nosotros lo que hicimos fue que
un año antes nos preparamos para hacerle
clase a nuestro hijo y el mayor que en
ese momento le tocaba cursar el primero
básico e hizo el contenido completo del
año en tres meses así no con respecto a
la pareja y ahí no tengo mucho nada que
decir pero siempre me llama la atención
que quizás en nuestra mayor empresa en
nuestra mayor asociación que es
encontrar esta media naranja
estemos tan a la deriva by nos enseñan o
nos entrenan desde chico solamente lo
hacemos con nuestros instintos con
respecto a lo último el miedo creo que
ahí sí todos lo tenemos todos estamos
muertos de susto
y un viaje estas características
comienzan cuando uno pierde el miedo
yo las primeras veces les voy a contar
esta realidad se me ocurre recién pero
la primera noche que alojamos ya así
libres y en un lugar no protegido y todo
no dormí no pegué el ojo nada me acuerdo
que tenía un machete para cortar leña y
no lo soltaba en toda la noche de puro
susto hasta que comprendí que quedarse
en cualquier parte aunque uno le dijeran
era ahí ahí comenzaba el viaje y ahí
está la frase de los niños que decían
papá la casa es chiquitita pero el
jardín es muy grande
entonces a lo que vine
esta es una canción que cuenta la
historia de este viaje
es una canción que se llama panamericana
y le canta obviamente al camino que le
lleva por este viaje pero también a la
unión a la unión de las américas
si se animan la vamos cantando y
cerramos este día maravilloso de
charlistas increíbles que nos llenan de
sueño cantando que eso nos va a hacer
irnos a la casa con mucha alegría y esto
dice más o menos así
me quedé sin casa me quedé sin plata me
quedé sin porta que atravesar me quedé
dormido no me queda en silencio y no
pude más
me quedé espera porque todo se fue a
llorar tranquilo para echar de mí para
ser pedazos lo que pensaba de la
realidad
y estuve sentado en la carretera semana
entera sin la billetera no sabía cómo
cuándo dónde iba a ir a parar
y me quedé en panamá que decir hielo me
quedé sin pega sin deber decir me quedé
sin tele me quedó gustando esa libertad
para salir corriendo sin pagar la cuenta
que la señorita me decía tanto que
seguramente ella lo que sí también
sumado mal
y me fui para no te cruce los desierto
me subí a la sierra sigue a las
estrellas me mire en sus aguas navegue
la selva estuve frente al mar y me senté
en su mesa tomé el switch y ahí estuve
de acuerdo y 20 con ella manos en la
lista de lo que nunca lo iban a olvidar
y ahora te dicen anda pana pana
panamericana si tu eres mi hermana
panamericana que le van a dejar
para la pana pana panamericana si tu
eres mi hermana la panamericana
enséñame a bailar
me quedé sin miedo me quedé sin culpa me
quedé sin reír me quedé sin multa me
quedé sin tiempo y me quedé sin prisa
[Música]
me quedé encerrado entre tus sonrisas me
quedé contigo me quedé contento me quedé
tendido como el pasto del viento me
quedé afuera me quedé en la tierra y no
vuelvo
y me fui para no sé lo que siento me
subí a la sierra sé que a las estrellas
vivencias no hay nadie que deba ser él
me estuve frente al mar y me senté en su
mesa tomé de esa chica y estuve de
acuerdo y baile con ella me anoté en la
lista de los que nunca la iban a olvidar
[Música]
van a ganar la panamericana sí pero en
mi hermana panamericana llévame a viajar
por el mundo y dice falta para nada la
panamericana si tú eres mi hermana
panamericanos
se llame a bailar y ahora decimos todo
mire
hoy
o no
de la palma
no
por favor
punto derecha
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]